a group of graduating students in the
u.s staged a protest in honor of sherina
barclay on saturday they carried photos
of her as they were awarded their
degrees in georgetown university in
washington d.c
they're demanding an independent
investigation into her killing a
palestinian-american student carried the
palestinian flag and refused to shake
the hand of the graduation speaker
u.s secretary of state
anthony blinken
let's now talk to that student nuran
alhamdan she joins us live from
washington dc thanks for being with us
so first of all what prompted you to
make that stand
thank you so much for having me sami i
really appreciate it what prompted
myself and my peers to have this stand
is really simple
we are all graduating with a master's
degree in arab studies from georgetown
university
and we've spent the past two years
learning about uh the colonial project
in the arab world and in particular the
colonial project that is the state of
israel
i myself as a palestinian american of
course have a very intimate
understanding of what israel inflicts on
palestinians as my grandparents are
survivors of the nakbe and my parents
have you know lived the lives of
palestinian refugees so
for us uh kind of the moment we knew
that lincoln was the speaker we knew for
a fact that we were going to send him a
message um it just so happened that a
few days later unfortunately the world
was shocked with the news uh regarding
the murder of shirin
and that to us gave us a very direct uh
compass in which to point our concerns
to so we were we were you know
protesting not only the incompetent u.s
role in the region and the frankly tooth
risk toothless remarks that the united
states has in regards to someone who is
an american citizen being murdered by a
foreign army that we are supposedly
allies with and bankroll uh by the
millions and billions of dollars it was
not just a statement about shidin the
martyr but it was also a larger
statement about justice for palestinians
and and to the occupation and
palestinian liberation more generally
and given the response
and given the fact that lincoln actually
confronted us at the end of commencement
it looks like the message was heard all
right i'm glad you mentioned that as
though you had an exchange
with the u.s secretary of state tell us
what was said what happened in that
exchange
yeah this is a great question and i want
to provide some uh backgrounds maybe to
some of the viewers uh before i answer
it
myself and my peers we had planned to
don the palestinian kofiya and to hold
posters of [ __ ]
this was the best that we could do in
order to encourage
the majority of our peers to participate
because some folks had issues with
student visas or their citizens of
you know countries where free speech is
not necessarily respected and so that
was the best way for us to incorporate
everyone and
this action was seen by blinken he saw
our posters we walked into the
procession of our graduation everyone
saw the kofi as everyone saw the posters
with the martyr shooting on them and
that message was heard
now my in my own interaction with
blinken this was actually completely
unplanned uh i did not wake up that day
and think that i'm going to walk by the
secretary of state on the stage and and
speak to him we had kind of assumed that
he's supposedly an important person with
better things to do and that he would
give his speech and leave
and so i was given a palestinian flag by
an american peer of mine has no
palestinian or arab background and i
carried the palestinian flag at my
undergraduate graduation so
this just seemed like continuing a
tradition to me
something that i knew i was going to do
after lincoln spoke and we realized oh
he's on stage and he's going to stay and
we're actually expected to fist bump or
handshake him
or shake his hand
not
for myself that was an impromptu
decision that i made in the moment that
i'm not going to fist bump him i'm not
going to shake his hand and i'm going to
convey the message that we're sending uh
with our silent protest a bit more
clearly to him while i walk by him on
stage and so
as i walked by him you know i first
received my diploma from the dean of the
school of foreign service and then i
walk by uh the secretary of state i'm
expected to you know
fist-bump him and instead i told him we
demand an independent investigation into
sharing abraham's murder now and we
demand an end to all uh us aid to the
israeli military now that's really all i
had time for
and i walked off stage you said that
sorry as you were passing him after you
got your degree right that was you
managed to get all that
wow okay
yeah that's and i think you can even see
me in the video i'm like shaking my head
and and telling him all of this trying
to relay that what did
you know on stage his reaction was a
very like
dismal like all right okay to be frank i
can't remember the exact one word reply
he had to me
but um
he definitely heard me because towards
the end of commencement he comes up to
me and i believe uh viewers can see this
in the video footage uh he kind of does
one of these at me before he steps off
the stage like don't leave and as he's
getting off the stage to leave the
commencement ceremony he stops right in
front of me and my peers we just so
happen to be in the first two front rows
because arab studies starts with a and
master's students are always in the
front
and so he comes up to me
because i happen to have spoken to him
before and he says i see you and i hear
you
and my response to that was
thank you but
we demand this independent investigation
it's very important this woman you know
was murdered
and to that his response was
we're committed to finding the truth and
that irked me because
myself and my peers are calling for an
independent investigation not because we
believe that there is any facts left to
find we know the israeli military
murdered shirin but per her family's
request they are requesting an
independent investigation because this
kind of thing going on the global record
is important it's a step to holding
israel accountable um now when that
accountability will happen certainly not
in today's right
current world and certainly not with the
current biden administration but it's
still important and so my exact response
in that moment to the secretary of state
was we know the truth shadeen was
murdered by the israeli military that we
bankroll we need to stop funding the
israeli military with american tax
dollars
and
as soon as i said that of course the the
hearing and seeing just seemed to
dissipate and and he walked away now and
i'm sure part of that is the
commencement ceremony had to end but i'm
sure part of it is the secretary's own
media training that you know not to
engage maybe any further with folks who
are calling him out all right well it's
uh thanks for coming and explaining all
of that it's been uh good good to get
your explanation and all that